غابت سنه ورجعت بثلاثه في ثلث الثلاثه
النجمه غاده عبد الرازق في تفاعلكم ومؤلفه
المسلسل ترد على الجدل حول القصه وبعد
انتهاء الهرش السابعه الجمهور كله بيسال
محمد شاهين ظالم ام مظلوم اهلا بكم
من بعد غياب عن الموسم الرمضاني السابق
بتعود النجمه غاده عبد الرازق لتخوض
السباق الرمضاني بقوه ضمن المسلسل ثلث
الثلاثه وهو من الاعمال اللي انطلقت من نص
الشهر وفي المسلسل غاده عبد الرازق طالعه
3 في 1 تلعب دور ثلاث شخصيات فريده فريال
وفرح وهم ثلاث اخوات توام كل وحده فيهم
بتعمل في مهنه مختلفه وبتصير معاهم احداث
مثيره ومن اول الحلقات بدات تشويق على طول
فريده اكتشفت خيانه زوجها اللي بعدها دبر
لها مكيده عشان يتخلص منها لكن كانت
الضحيه اختها فريال وبدات الاحداث
اتنين مفلسين التالين قتله خلصوا على بعض
[موسيقى]
ولا
نعقل كده ونكمل بقيه اتفقنا
الميتين لا يمكن يصحوا
[موسيقى]
ممكن ينتبه
السكينه دي ما بتقطعش اللحمه كويس انا مش
ضعيفه زيك
وعمري ما سبت راجل يتحكم في حياتي ومع انه
المسلسل انطلق من كم يوم بس لكن الاصداء
حقيقه بادئه وبقوه وردود الافعال بتشيل في
المسلسل واللي جلسه بتقدمه او بتقدموا
غاده عبد الرازق فيه ثلاث شخصيات
هو معنا من القاهره النجمه غاده عبد
الرازق اهلا فيك معنا يا غاده وكل عام
وانت بالف خير ومنوره في رمضان
وانت بالصحه والسلامه يا رب حبيبتي
المشهد اللي احنا عرضناه الان اخر شيء
يعني صار ترند على السوشيال ميديا والناس
صارت كلها تبعته يعني طبعا هي فكره يعني
جهنميه جهنميه جهنميه
أعرف منك انت يا غاده ايش احسن حل للتعامل
مع الخاين
بصي والله انا يعني مش هرد الرد اللي انا
اقول ان هم يعني يتعمل فيه كده احنا شويه
بنعمل حاجات طبعا عشان تعجب الناس عشان اه
دراما لكن عموما عموما ايمن ادم خاين او
كذاب
شيء طبيعي طبعا ان انت
تبعدي عنه تماما تشيليه من حياتك
ما تحاوليش تقولي فرصه اولى وفرصه تانيه
لان
كثره الفرص دي بتخليكي انت بعد كده تطلعي
مبررات
للخاين عشان تتعايش معه
ده في حد ذاته انا بقول ان ده خطر خطر جدا
ممتاز هذه حكمه اولى لكل النساء من الذي
بدانا بحكمه في موضوع الخيانه خلينا نرجع
للمسلسل المسلسل يعني ايش اللي يشهدك فيه
وخلاك تقولي انا ابغى ارجع هذا الرمضان
بهذا العمل
المكتوب حلو قوي انه طرد شخصيات وانا
اتعرض عليا كتير زمان اني اعمل فكره
التوائم بس كان دايما اتنين مش عارفه ايه
حاجات كده فكنت بشوفها مستهلكه قوي وما
فيهاش جديده اقدمه للناس اول مره احس ان
التلاته
شبه بعض يعني انا كنت متمسكه جدا اني ما
اعملش فرق في الشكل فيهم تماما تمام واحده
بقى شعرها اصفر واحده احمر وواحده
لان شفت توائم كتير تلاتات بنات واولاد
نسخه من بعضهم يعني درجه ان هم هم بيكلموا
بيكلموا زي بعض
فحبيت الفكره دي قوي وحبيت الساسبنس
والحاجه النفسيه لان انا بحس ان دي
المنطقه اللي انا بتميز بها او يعني
نجحت نجحتي فيها بقوه
الحمد لله
قبل كده طبعا كمان ثلاث حاجه ودي الاهم
اني
رجعت حاده نفسي عشان تعملي تلات شخصيات
التلاته شبه بعض خارجيا لكن داخليا
مختلفين تماما عن بعض
فكريا
حتى حتى اكلهم يعني في واحده فيهم
فيجيتريان في واحده مش عارفه ايه دي كانت
تحدي بالنسبه للغاده عبد الرازق ان نلعب
تلات شخصيات في وقت واحد واللي اصعب كمان
ان الناس ما تعرفش ان انا بقف قصاد نفسي
بمثل وما فيش حد قدامي ايوه انا حابه تشرح
يا هادي الجزئيه يا غاده لانه كتير ناس ما
يعرفوها انت بتمثلي مشاهد مع نفسك انت
قدام نفسك اشرحي لنا بتعمليها
هقول لك يعني مثلا هيبقى مثلا زي في مشهد
مثلا التلاته مع بعض فمثلا اتنين قاعدين
وواحده واقفه بلبس الاول فريده واخش على
الكرسي
واكلم فرح هنا واكلم فريال هنا بس هو ما
فيش حد هو في هواء وبعدين ارجع البس فرح
اقعد الناحيه التانيه واكلم فريال كده
واكلم فريده كده وبرضو هوا مفيش حد وبعدين
البس فريال اللي هي الثالثه
واطلع اتكلم مع فريده وفرح بس انا بتكلم
الاثنين كرسي فاضيين ولكن انت خالي بقى
معي 180 شخص
العاملين معي فانا ببقى واقفه قدامهم كاني
زي المجنونه بكلم نفسي
وتغيري شخصيتك وشكلك وكل شيء وتتكلمي مره
يعني الموضوع فعلا مو سهل وافهمك لما
تقولي تحدي جدا
ومطلوب كمان مني بقى ان انا وانا بمثل
مثلا تتخانق مثلا مع اخت من الاخوات
ابقى انا جوايا بمثل هي هي هترد علي ازاي
اللي هي انا يعني انا هرد على نفسي انا
ازاي في الخناقه دي جننتينا يا غاده ههه
فانا متخيله اتفقنا
متخيله فريق العمل طيب بس كمان المره هذه
يمكن كمان اللي مختلف انه 15 حلقه وبادئين
من النص رمضان ليش هذه الخطوه
هقول لك ليه لان العمل ده كان مكتوب من
سنه ونص او سنتين وكان 30 حلقه اوكي وكنا
هنخش نصور حصل لنا مشكله
قعدنا حوالي 65 يوم خلاص خدنا القرار ان
احنا مش هنخش المسلسل ده السنه دي السنه
الجايه فحصل برضو
مناوشات كده وجينا قعدنا مع بعض
وكان فيه يعني اصرار فقلت لهم لو في اصرار
قوي هيبقى 15 مش هقدر اجذب ب 30 لان العمل
دوت عايز شغل عايز تركيز قوي وعايزني انا
كممثله ابقى حاضره ذهنيا ونفسيا عشان اعرف
ارجع تاني يعني عشان اعمل اللي انا عايزاه
اوكي لما وصلت لده وضمنته الحمد لله رب
العالمين
دخلت صورت ايوه طيب طيب وبصور لحد دلوقتي
ايوه انا عارفه انت طالعه من اللوكيشن هذا
القصر اللي انت ساكنه فيه المفروض في
المسلسل يعني
ابو 100 مليون
متابعين معاكي متابعين معاكي لاحداث
بتتحرك جلسه بسرعه واحنا جالسين بنتابع
معاك الموضوع طيب بس كمان يعني خلي بالك
على فكره انا منت انا من متابعين قناه
العربيه يوميا يا حبيبه قلبي يا سلام
هذا الكلام
بس والله ده حقيقه انا مش بجامل لان انا
اول حاجه باصحى الصبح وانا بفطر لازم اسمع
الاخبار ايوه حتى بالليل لما باجي انام هو
بيجي مثلا قنوات تانيه اول ما انزل الصبح
وافتح التلفزيون
مقفول عليها من بالليل
لا برافو يا غاده تستاهلي عشر نجمات على
هذا الموضوع ممتاز وكمان ركز على تفاعل
والله العظيم ركزي على تفاعلكم وعلى ساره
بس دي فعلا والله حقيقه من عيني حاضر طيب
غاده خليني كمان اقول لك يمكن واحده من
الاشياء اللي كمان قالوا انه سببت يعني
كده دوشه عندكم كان انه تغيير المخرج انه
صار في اعتذار من المخرج الاساسي هو ايش
صار صار في مشاكل صار يعني ايش اللي صار
[موسيقى]
من قبل ما احمد يطلع في البرنامج ويقول ان
في مشاكل حتى انا نفسي
استغربت قوي انا واحمد عمران متخانقنا عمر
ما كان في بينا خناقه حتى قصاد بعض كده
وزعقنا مع بعض فانا قلت اكيد اكيد حد وصل
له او حد قال له ده فبالتالي هو خد الخطوه
من غير ما يسالني فاهمه
بس
فلم ده حصل في الجول قالوا لي طيب انت
شايفه ايه يعني ليلى لا لا لا ليلى هتيجي
وليلى هتشتغل وبعدين دي مهنه احنا يا
جماعه احنا مش مش الممثلين ابدا اللي بصفي
حسابات شخصيه شغلتي
مهنتي دي اكل عيشي دي دي حاجه
كنت بحلم بها طول حياتي هي اللي عملتني
فهل هنا ابقى سته ادخل في شغلي اصل مين
قالوا فلان عادوا لا لا لا وبالذات ان بجد
بجد
انا ما بكرهوش انا مش عارفه هو جايب
الكلام ده منين الحاجه الوحيده بس اللي
قلتها له قلت احمد قبل ما تقول اتاكد لان
ممكن انا انا حكايتي عدت انا ست ذكيه
وخبرتي بسني ممكن ده يحصل مع حد تاني ما
يبقاش عنده خبرتي او ما يبقاش زيي فهماني
فتحصل بجد مشكله هو بس عشان يعني التوضيح
هو جاي الوقت انه تم استبعاده من عمل
بسببك يعني
فانت بتقولي انه لا هذا الشيء ما صار حتى
اوكي طيب
خليني كمان يصير يمكن انقلك على موضوع
التسارع الاحداث يعني نحن عدينا الان يعني
في اربع حلقات وكل حلقه مليانه مليانه
مليانه يعني يعني انتم متعمدين تعملوا هذا
الشيء انه الحلقه يكون رتمها مليان
اه اكيد بس اقول لك حاجه هو اللي خدمنا ان
احنا اصلا بقول لك كنا كاتبين المسلسل من
سنتين اوكي وكانوا 30 حلقه انا مختصرته
مشدودين فلما اختصرت الثلاثين اللي انت
واخده فيهم مجهود جامد قوي وعملتيهم في 15
ما بقاش عندك نفس خلاص خلاص
حابه بس اسالك اسئله سريعه في المواقع
اللي هي بتصنف المسلسلات حاطينه انه
المسلسل للكبار فقط بتتفقي مع هذا التصنيف
الكبار فقط
مش عارفه حاطينه كده يمكن علشان المشهد
انه انه في خيانه وكذا
على الشاشه صاير
بيفتحوا الحاجات دي على النت كله بينعرض
على الشاشه كده طيب خليني بدي اسالك كمان
شوي تاني انت قبل صرحتي كمان انك انت في
ايام التصوير الطويله ما بتصومي وتصريحك
ده اكيد شفتي الجدل اللي عمله اصلا بشكل
عام غاده انت اي تصريح لك بتعملي على طول
جدل وتردد والكلام ده كله فانت لما قلت
انا ايام التصوير الطويله
جدل على هذا الموضوع بتحبي توضحي شيء عند
الكلام
اوضح انا ما قلتش كده على فكره انا قلت
ساعات لو طبقت في التصوير في التصوير
يومين او تلاته ورا بعض
ما اقدرش اصوم فيهم لاني باخد ادويه ادويه
سابوا كل اللي انا قلته ده ايوه
اصلها ما بتصومش في رمضان لما بتشتغل
ممتاز غدا انك انت الان وضحتي هذا الموضوع
لانه العناوين فعلا كلها اجتزقت جزء معين
يعني فجيد انك انت وضحتي هذا الشيء غدا
انا عارفه انك انت بتصوري وانك حابه تقولي
عايزه اقول كل سنه وانتم طيبين ورمضان
كريم وعيد سعيد وبحبكم جدا احنا اللي
بنحبك اكثر بس انا كمان العربي بكل ناس
انا حابه بس كمان غاده طبعا احنا حنستمر
في الحديث عن المسلسل وواضح انه اصلا
الايام الجايه الحديث مستمر على المسلسل
هيكون لانه كل يوم فعلا بيكون ترند يعني
بس معانا ان شاء الله كمان مؤلفه المسلسل
وهي حترد على بعض الجدل اللي صاير على هذه
القصه والدعاوى اللي طالعه على المسلسل
ذلك واحنا حنسالها عن هذا الموضوع بس كنت
حابه اشوف اذا انت حضرتك عندك تعليق او
تحبي تضيفي شيء على هذا الموضوع
هقول حاجه واحده بس دايما الشجر المثمره
بيحدفوها بالطوب انا فاكره كويس جدا ان كل
الاعمال اللي انا عملتها اللي كانت ناجحه
وعملت بوم من اول اسبوع اتقال عليها نفس
الكلام
وهفكرك ونفس الكلام ده حصل في سبق الاصرار
وحكايه حياه والكابوس وحدوته مره نفس ده
بالظبط بالملي
دايما يعني ما شاء الله عليك يعني النجاح
كمان بيجي مع نقدر ننكر الشي والسؤال
الاخير يا غاده كيف ما شاء الله بتفضلي
حلوه
عشان نفسيتي كويسه
حلو الجواب ده كلنا بنقول طب والله لو انا
يعني نفسيتي انا نفسي تكون كويسه كمان يا
غاده على كده حاحاول اخلي نفسيتي كويسه
دلوقتي انت حلوه ههه خلاص اسمع يا غاده
انت احسن مسلسل في رمضان وانت عشره نجمات
كل شيء انتي خلاص انا انت نجمتي 10 على 10
انت الان خلاص
حبيبتي بالتوفيق وانا بقول للناس صراحه
يشوفوا المسلسل لانه فعلا احداث متسارعه
ومختلف عن كل اللي موجود حقيقه يعني الحمد
لله
نورتينا يا غاده نورتينا نورتينا وانا
عارفه دينك من التصوير ارجعي للتصويرك
وكميه تصويرك وبالتوفيق دائما وابدا
حبيبتي شكرا لك
احنا تكلمنا في الجزء الاول مع في
البرنامج من حلقتنا اليوم مع النجمه غاده
عبد الرازق عن مسلسلها تلت التلاته
والاصدقاء الكبيره اللي عملها المسلسل لكن
مع الاصداء والارشادات كمان ذكرنا انه في
جدل وعناوين كثير شفناها عن سرقه المسلسل
من مسلسلات اجنبيه ودعاوى قضائيه من كاتبه
بتقول انها صاحبه المسلسل الحقيقيه وغيرهم
خلينا نلخص لكم الكلام السائد للان اولا
من وقت ما نزل بوستر العمل والاتهامات
نزلت عليه انه بيتشابه مع بوستر مسلسل
مكسيكي طيب في كمان اصوات طلعت قالت لا
ترى المسلسل ماخوذ ومقتبس من كم عمل
تانيين هم مسلسل اجنبي اسمه في فيلم اسمه
لافنج طيب وفي كمان انتقادات وكلام توجه
للكاتبه انها حولت المسلسل الى 15 حلقه في
اللحظه الاخيره لان مالح تكتب 30 حلقه
كامله افك هذا طلعت كمان كاتبه اسمها سو
شاهين اتهمت الصناع بالسرقه وقالت انها
عرضت النص على النجمه غاده عبد الرازق من
قبل وكان اسمه لعبه التغيير وانها كانت
متفقه معاها على البدء بالتصوير في نوفمبر
ولكن غاده قطعت التواصل معها والكاتبه
انصدمت بس شافت بوستر المسلسل وهي الان
رفعت دعوه قضائيه ضد غاده وكل صناع العمل
واتهمتهم بالسرقه او بسرقه العمل منها
تحديدا وطالبت في دعواها بوقف عرض المسلسل
فورا كل ما سبق هذا للان ما طلع عليه ولا
اي رد رسمي واحنا قلنا ما في الا كاتبه
المسلسل بنفسها اللي تطلع وتوضح وحتكون
معنا الان في اول مقابله لها ورد رسمي على
كل الجدل الكاتبه طبعا هبه الحسيني الكلام
هذا عن التشابه والاقتباس او ايا كان اسمه
في جمهور اتفق معه
ومعنا من القاهره مؤلفه مسلسل تلت الثلاثه
هبه الحسيني اهلا فيك معنا يا هبه وكل سنه
وانت طيبه
وانت طيبه ميرسي قوي اهلا بك طبعا هبه
يعني المسلسل بدا عرضه وطبعا زي ما ذكرنا
للاستاذ عبد الرازق انه طبعا في نجاح في
حديث عنه عامل ترند كل هذا الكلام بس برضو
مصاحبه الكثير من الجدل والجدل هذا في
الموضوع خصوصا يخصك انت بالدرجه الاولى
اللي هو القصه في كذا اتهام اول شيء في
اتهامات انه مقتبس من اعمال اجنبيه هل
شفتي هذه الاعمال
قدرتي تراجعي او شيء تشوفي وجه الشبه اللي
بيتكلموا عنه الناس
بصي هو من اول ما بدانا اصلا اعلنا اصلا
عن العمل في كم كبير جدا من حمله كده تم
شنها فجاه انا مش فاهمه يعني ازاي حد
ينتقد او او يتوقع قصه حاجه من مجرد
البوستر هو لسه ما شافهاش فمن البدايه
خالص كان فيه ربط كده غريب جدا والحقيقه
ان انا عايزه بس ابتدي كلامي كده بحاجه
اعتقد ان هي هتبقى بديهيه انه في حاجتين
لا يتفقان ابدا التكرار والتشويق ما فيهاش
حاجه مكرره تحقق تشويق والحاله اللي احنا
عايشينها دلوقتي مع المشاهدين على
السوشيال ميديا وحضراتكم اكيد بتتابعوا
بدليل ان انتم معانا اصلا النهارده لو
احنا مش ناجحين انتم مش هتبقوا معنا ان
الناس قاعده على اعصابها لا عارفه مين عاش
مين مات مين جاي مين رايح اللي هيحصل
فازاي حاجه مكرره او بلغه السوء منحوته
بين قوسين هتبقى محققه تشويق يعني هوكم
ما يجتمعوش دي نقطه النقطه التانيه انا
ليه مش عارفه يعني ليه لما الخواجه بيروح
لقضيه حقيقيه او حاله نفسيه او حادثه حصلت
في بلد ما ويعملها في مسلسل في فيلم
بنسقفله وبنقوله برافو بس احنا لما نيجي
ناخد منها لاين او ناخذ منها خط حادثه
حقيقيه هيلاقي الناس بتقول لك اصل انت
سارق من الخواجه لا هو الخواجه لا يمتلك
الحدث الحقيقي وانا عايزه اقول كل
البوستات اللي شفتها
والمقارنات اللي انا قريتها ما بين
المسلسل وما بين مسلسلات اخرى او افلام
اخرى كلها يعني كل الاعمال اللي تم
وقناتها كلها مستوحى من اعمال حقيقيه اذا
لو فرضنا الجدلا ان انا اخدت لاين من
الحادثه الحقيقيه دي هل انا مطلوب منك يا
كاتبه انه اشير للكاتب الامريكي او
الدنماركي او الروسي او الكوري اللي اخذ
من نفس الحادثه الحقيقيه ليه هو مش مصدري
انا مصدري الواقع الحقيقيه القضيه او
الحاله النفس هل هل انت مستوحيه اي شيء يا
هبه من قصص حقيقيه
طبعا بس انا مش مطلوب مني ان انا احرق
مسلسل وهو نفسه بيتعرض يعني هل اطلع ارد
اطلع ارد عشان اكسب جدل يعني جدل على
السوشيال ميديا
وجدل افتراضي عشان احرق مسلسلي انا كل
اقدر اقوله من خلالكم انه
الاحداث ابعد بكتير بكتير بكتير بكثير من
اللي بيتم طرحه طيب بس بيتم
انه مو بس انه يعني مقتبس من اشياء اجنبيه
او يعني زي ما قلتي منحوت او كذا في كاتبه
طلعت واتهاماتكم ورفعت دعوه وقالت انه هي
عرضت الفكره والسيناريو
هذا على غاده تمام صح ما هي بقى نشرت مش
هي نشرت المعالجه اللي كانت نشرت المعالجه
فعلا المنشوره والمسلسل بيتعرض الحكم
للجمهور والحكم الثاني للقضاء لانه هي
يعني برضو المعالجه اللي نشرتها فيها برضه
ثلاث اخوات وانهم بيكونوا توائم وجريمه
بترتكب وهكذا
ايه المشكله انا عندي بنتين توام واول ما
بدات اشتغل على المشاكل اللي بيعيشها
التوائم الامراض النفسيه والحالات اللي
ممكن تصاب التوائم في نفس الوقت ده انا
اتكلمت انا واستاذه غاده عن ايه الافكار
اللي ممكن نشتغل عليها احنا شغالين عن
مسلسل ده بقى سنتين لان احنا اصلا كنت
هشتغل انا واستاذه غاده قبل كده يعني في
رمضان اللي فات مش في رمضان ده وكان عندنا
مجموعه افكار كثيره بنطرحها وبنتناقش فيها
وطورنا الفكره مع بعض واشتغلنا عليها مع
بعض همم هي كان عندها رغبه ان هي تشتغل
على خطوط معينه لها التحدي ليها كممثله
وانا كان عندي مخزون من القصص عن التوائب
من خلال تجربتي في ان انا انجبت توام
بنتين برده متطابقين بالمناسبه الله يخلي
لكم
الله يخليك
فبالتالي احنا دماغنا التقت مع بعض
وخلقنا حاجه هبه حاسه انك مزعوجه جدا من
الموضوع
لا انا بس حاسه انه الموضوع دوت يعني حاسه
ان في ناس مش قادره تصدق او تستوعب او
تقتنع ان احنا في
المجتمع العربي يعني نقدر نعمل حاجه حلوه
لازم لو شفنا حاجه حلوه نفكر على طول اول
حاجه تيجي في بالنا هو احنا واخدينها من
مين لا احنا واخدين من نفس السورس اللي
بياخد منه مين ده برده يعني هي الفكره ان
المجتمع والعالم مليء بالقصص وفي الحواديت
الفكره انت هتتعالجه ازاي وبعدين احنا
عندنا لسه احنا دلوقتي بنعرض الحلقه
الخامسه يعني
ان شاء الله يعني على خير بقيه المسلسل
يتعرض والحكم في النهايه للجمهور يعني
مفيش ما فيش اي حاجه من اللي بتتقال على
السوشيال ميديا
تقدر ان هي تحكم على العشر حلقات
الجايين ايه احنا اه لا وعلى العموم يعني
هي كمان الكاتبه الاخرى رفعت دعوه
والمحكمه راح تنظر فيه الموضوع نحن بنشكرك
على هذه التوضيحات وهذه المداخله شكرا لك
وطبعا تمنياتنا لك بالتوفيق في المسلسل
كانت معنا من القاهره مؤلفه مسلسل ثلث
الثلاثه هبه الحسين شكرا لك
محمد شاهين اسم في اخر كم سنه بيصدمنا
صدمات سعيده جدا في دور بعد دور من الا
انا لموضوع عائلي احلام سعيده لسوتش
بالعربي مفاجات وصدمات رائعه بفاجئنا فيها
محمد شاهين لكن هذا كله ممكن نقول انه
زهروا نور هذا الرمضان بشكل وشخصيه جديده
ومختلفه على محمد اللي هو ادم في الهرش
السابعه اللي من يوم ما بدا عرضه الى ان
خلص وهو مجنن الناس ادم هذا طيب وصبور ولا
قاسي ولا مظلوم ولا ايش وضعه لا عندي
مشكله كبيره جدا
تتلكك بقى في الاصل
هو انت متجوزاني عشان تقراي من عيشه في
البيت اهلك
ما فيش حاجه مهمه واحده زهقانه ومستني
روحها اكثر واحد كنت واقف جنبك
على الرغم من انه شخصيات ادم اللي قدامها
محمد شاهين مختلفه عنه تماما مثل ما كان
هو صرح سابقا يعني هو لما اتزوج ولا خط
تجارب ومشاكل الحياه الزوجيه ولا انجب
ولكن قدر يتالق في الدور ويبهر الجميع فيه
ادور ادم والاشادات في على المنصات كانت
اكبر دليل
ومعنى النجم محمد شاهين اهلا فيك يا محمد
ومبروك النجاح
اهلا بك يا ساره الله يبارك فيك ميرسي جدا
جدا وشكرا على التقديم الحلوه دي لا ابدا
انت تستاهل اكتر من كده يعني انت عيشت انا
حلقات يعني في البدايه حبيناك بعدين صرنا
متنرفزين منك واختلطت مشاعرنا معك وكل هذا
الكلام
اول شيء يعني انت طبعا قريب من يعني انت
من هذا العمل والعمل نجح مع الناس بشكل
كبير ليش الناس حست انه هذا العمل حقيقي
في وسط كثير اعمال ثانيه بتنعرض ما حد شاف
انها قريبه منه قد كده
والله من البدايه خالص خالص يعني من
الكتابه
مالين عون وسرد كاتبين سكريبت الكلام فيه
حقيقي والمواقف حقيقيه
والحوار فيه حقيقي جدا ما بين الشخصيات
يعني وبعدين
قبليهم بقى في كريم شناوي وهو
عايز يعمل حاجه يعني واقعيه حقيقيه
انا كان لازم يعني او كلنا يعني كل
الممثلين هم بالديكور برده مهندس الديكور
علي حسام ومدير التصوير مصطفى فهمي برده
من الابطال
يعني اظهروا العمل يعني
كل الناس
معظم الناس كانوا فاكرين
دي ده ديكور ومهندس الديكور هو المباني
بتاع ادم ونادين وسلمى وسيف
ومدير التصوير هو اللي منور البيوت بالشمس
يعني قصدي نهار والليل كل ده يعني مصطفى
هو اللي عمله
فكنا احنا كمان برضو ممثلين يعني لازم
برضو احنا كمان نبقى حقيقيين
كل واحد دور من حته ازاي يعني يلاقي
الكلاكس اللي هو بيعمله ده ويطلعه حقيقي
يعني والحمد لله يعني الموضوع كله طلع
يعني في روح
عقيقيه ما فيش تمثيل قوي يعني
وده حتى مش يعني والله يعني مش عايز اقول
يعني هو
كل حاجه طلعت كده يعني
زي ما احنا اه يعني هو كمان يعني مفيش
اتجاه يعني مش كريم جه قال لنا يا جماعه
احنا عايزين نبقى خالص خالص مره واحده
يعني مع كل ده بيحصل وبيزود بقى عليه كريم
من الحقيقيه اكثر في في تفصيل في في جمل
في لحظه
انت الشخص زي ما ذكرت انت بعيد يعني عن
عالم المتزوجين يعني والعلاقات الزوجيه
والعيال والكلام ده كله يعني كيف جلست
اقنعتنا انك فعلا مش طايق نفسك ومش طايق
العيال ومش طايقها لنادين يعني كيف
اقنعتنا
والله بصي يا ساره يعني ايه ربنا يوفقني
الحمد لله يعني
كمان انا عندي خبرات كده صغيره
يعني الناس اللي حواليا اصحابي اخويا
الناس اعرفهم قرايبي
وناس يعني عاشرتهم من اول من قبل ما
يتجوزه لغايه لما اتجوزوا بعد ما اتجوزه
بكل حاجه في التفاصيل دي كلها تقريبا
شفتها يعني شفتها قدام عيني
يعني الناس بتنفذها مع بعض يعني فاهمه
يعني فده يعني فعلا بالمبدا انت فضحت
اصحابك وفضحت اخوك مصر كلها العالم كله
على فكره
في واحد صاحبي يعني مش مصري وحياه ربنا
يعني
وبعدين
انا واصحابي
اتفرجوا على وبعدين
ده بيحصل عندنا بيحصل عندكم ايه بصي ده
بيحصل في كل بيت في العالم كله يعني يمشي
العالم العربي بس العالم كله يعني
طب لو انت مثلا الان لو يعني انت خارج هذا
العمل وطالعت في ادم تقول ظالم او مظلوم
والله هو ظالم ومظلوم يعني هو ادم يعني مش
يعني اه بيعمل حاجات تمام كويسه جدا وكل
حاجه بس برضو هو غلطان في شويه حاجات زي
ما نادين برضو
ظالمه ومظلومه هم الاتنين يعني هم
الاتنينوا بعض وظلموا نفسهم
يستاهل اللي عملته داليا فيه
هو هو اصل ادم غلبان قوي
بس ثانيه واحده والله العظيم هقول لك ليه
هاقول لك ليه والله لان هم الاثنين ما
عندهمش تجارب يعني ما خطبوش مثلا وفسخوه
يعني ما عندهمش علاقات
هم الاثنين عرفوا بعض في المدرسه وبعدين
كملوا لغايه
لما شفناهم فتخيلي الاثنين دول ما عندهمش
اي خبره في اي علاقات خالص هم الاثنين بس
هو دايما الانطباع عند الحب الحب ينقذ كل
شيء بسنته في المسلسل خليتونا يعني نؤمن
انه الحب ما بيساوي نكله بعد الزواج يعني
ههه
ههه 22 سنه
محمد نقدر نقول انه يعني انت مضرب عن
الزواج بسبب اللي شايفه حوالينك وبسب هذه
الاشياء
مش مضرب والله مش حكايه اضراب انا يعني
عمري ما قلت انا انا مجرم انا مش هتجوز
الموضوع جاي كله بالصدفه يعني انا
كل حاجه
بعقلي وقلبي الشغل الحياتي
اصحابي اللي حاجه اللي تريحني بعملها ما
بتريحنيش
ما بتغطي على حاجه علشان
مش بقول ان انا عارف ايه اخرتها في اي
حاجه في شغل او يعني او حاجه حياتيه بس
بحس ان انا يعني يعني شويه عارف ممكن ايه
اللي يحصل شويه قدام
الظروف اللي انا شايفها قدامي يعني
كانت ملاء ماليه تخليني ادخل في علاقه
جواز لغايه دلوقتي
السابعه اكد لك الموضوع بزياده لا لا خالص
والله العظيم ابدا لا لا ابدا بالعكس ازاي
دول الاثنين يعني اللي هم في الاخر يعني
مالهمش غير بعض يعني يعني بيتفرج في الاخر
لو جينا هنلاقي ان الاثنين لسه بيحبوا بعض
الاحسن ان هم يرجعوا لبعض بيحبوه في تعاسه
والنهايه جت مفتوحه وعجب هذا الشيء كثير
ناس
لا بالاتفاق ما فيش تعايسه هم هم في الاخر
عملوا ايه اتكلموا فضفضوا
ده وجهه نظره وجهه نظرهوش سامعين بعض
انا حاسه انه انا وانت عاملين الان على
الهواء
[ضحك]
يعني انا وانت هنفتح قلوبنا وانا هحكي لك
على زواجي وانت رح تحكي لي على الموضوع
ونقعد بقى يلا نفتح قلوبنا لبعض
بالشكل ده حسيت نفسك عشه اللون ده
دكتور بقى يعني
الناس كمان من وقت يعني الاعمال السابقه
ناس حابه يعني حبيتك انت وامينه خليل حابه
العلاقه هذه او التعاون فريق العمل هذا
انت سامعني محمد
اه اوكي ايه فكنت حابه اسالك عن امينه
تحديدا
خصوصا انكم طول الوقت مع بعض يعني
وبتصرخوا
يعني احنا مرينا بكل
المراحل حبينا بعض وغيرنا على بعض
[موسيقى]
وهزقنا
كل المراحل اللي علينا مع بعض زمان ودي
تاني مره يعني يمكن زمان ما كانش فيه
مشاهد بيننا بس المره دي مفيش مشاهد غير
مع بعض حاجه حلوه جدا امينه من الممثلين
اللي بيساعدوا الواحد ان هو يعمل حاجه
كويسه
وان احنا يعني نوصل للدرجه دي من
المصداقيه هي
ممثله مريحه جميله
اييي لذيذه
مشاطره
حقيقي عينيها فيها حاجات كتير جدا
حقيقه
حقيقي احب ان انا اشتغل مع امينه كتير
ايوه وحتى هي في شخصيتها في الحياه
الطبيعيه رائعه ايضا طيب سريعا محمد ايه
سوتس في جزء ثاني
صحتك طمني على صحتك قبل فتره كان عندك
يعني تعبت شويه طمني على صحتك غيرت اسلوب
حياتك شيء الحمد لله زي الفل
حاجات كتير لازم اغير حاجات كتير
والحمد لله دلوقتي اتمنى بصحه جيده الحمد
لله
لا الحمد لله الحمد لله وسلامه قلبك اصلا
وهو انت مريح نفسك لا تتزوج يا محمد
انت مش ناقص يا ابني ههه
والله على فكره ممكن مره واحده مثلا بكره
تلاقيني متجوز يعني عادي
طب اعزمني على الفرح عشان عشان ابتدي
القصه من البدايه اشوف القصه البدايه وسنه
اولى والسنه الثانيه وكذا والكلام ده كله
ههه
محمد كيف اخبارك
شكرا لك نورتنا نورتنا نورتنا نورت نورت
نورت كان معنى النجم محمد شاهين شكرا لك
مشاهدينا باي باي